para sentir el mundo los nervios envían
señales eléctricas hacia y desde la
médula espinal y el cerebro los sensores
de todo nuestro cuerpo recogen
información sobre nuestro entorno
esta información se envía mediante
señales a nuestro cerebro a través de
una serie de células nerviosas cada
señal eléctrica se transporta de un
extremo a otro de una célula nerviosa
mediante unos conductos llamados canales
iónicos las partículas cargadas llamadas
iones pasan por los canales a lo largo
del nervio lo que ayuda a generar la
corriente eléctrica al final del nervio
la señal se traslada al siguiente a
través de unas sustancias químicas
llamadas
neurotransmisores la comunicación con el
cerebro se produce a través de las vías
y los centros nerviosos de la base del
cerebro llamada tronco encefálico el
tronco encefálico ayuda a controlar el
sueño el ritmo cardíaco y la respiración
la migraña es una enfermedad en la que
una o varias partes de este sistema de
comunicación no funcionan correctamente
muchas secciones de adn denominadas
genes programan los canales iónicos los
neurotransmisores y otras estructuras
que sustentan estas vías nerviosas en
algunas personas con migraña los cambios
heredados en los genes llamados
mutaciones pueden hacer que el sistema
de comunicación se vuelva hipersensible
la mayoría de las mutaciones no causan
directamente la migraña pero en
combinación pueden explicar por qué hay
tantas formas y síntomas de la
enfermedad de la migraña estos genes
mutados afectan al funcionamiento de
otras partes del cuerpo en consecuencia
las personas con migraña también pueden
padecer ansiedad depresión accidentes
cerebrovasculares epilepsia
hipotiroidismo síndrome del intestino
irritable dolor del piso pélvico
fibromialgia y enfermedad de sobren
entre otros
cada ataque suele tener tres o cuatro
fases las fases típicas de una crisis de
migraña son el pródromo que comienza
horas antes del dolor de cabeza el aura
el dolor de cabeza y el post dromo el
pródromo incluye síntomas sutiles como
bostezos fatiga o mal humor
experimentada sólo por algunas personas
las obras pueden ser cambios visuales de
corta duración como destellos de luz zig
zags o puntos ciegos las auras también
pueden incluir en tu me cimiento
confusión vértigo o incluso debilidad
muscular las cefaleas fuertes pueden
producirse en un solo lado de la cabeza
y suelen durar de cuatro a 72 horas
otros posibles síntomas son la
sensibilidad a la luz y al ruido o las
náuseas
por último durante el post como la
persona siente que tiene resaca que dura
uno o dos días más los ataques de
migraña suelen ser provocados por
estímulos o desencadenantes específicos
tales como aumento del estrés cambio de
clima dormir demasiado o muy poco o
ciertos alimentos
dado que puede ser un efecto acumulativo
de varios desencadenantes evitar tantos
desencadenantes conocidos como sea
posible puede ayudar a reducir el número
de ataques para la planificación del
tratamiento es importante distinguir la
migraña en función de la frecuencia y el
carácter de los ataques menos de 15 días
de dolor de cabeza al mes es migraña
episódica 15 o más dolores de cabeza al
mes son migraña crónica cada año
alrededor del 3% de las personas con
migraña episódica pasan a tener migrañas
crónicas este empeoramiento de los
síntomas puede deberse a cambios
hormonales o daños cerebrales acumulados
por años de ataques de migraña aunque la
migraña rara vez es mortal es una
enfermedad invisible que puede robar
años de tiempo de calidad para obtener
más información sobre la migraña hablé
con su proveedor de atención médica o
visite my way in the shoulders punto org